hi Jason Harris I'm a senior front-end
developer today I'm going to be talking
about advanced typesetting in
Mathematica and how you can create your
own customized notations in Mathematica
to affect whatever notation is in your
individual field be it chemistry physics
math computer science or whatever we'll
be able to extend Mathematica with new
notations and you'll get you'll learn
how to do it in this workshop
okay at what we're waiting I just wanted
to point out that you might want to go
this is going to be an interactive sort
of workshop so if you want to follow it
the the notebook is already available
unpassable if you go to this particular
session click on that link right there
that's really small and it will download
the the notebook onto your laptop and
you can follow along with some of the
examples as we actually go so probably
want to do that and I think my time has
already started so I'll kick off so
welcome to this this workshop on
advanced typesetting so this will follow
on to some degree from from what each I
sort of said and it'll probably go into
a bit more depth about some of the
topics that he he went quite fast over
so this talk it's going to explore that
the whole goal of this talk is for
enable you to be able to actually enter
your own notations and and in
Mathematica and do computations with
them we don't just want to look pretty
we want to be able to do computations
and so of course math is big there's
many fields out there you're never
really we're never going to be able to
build in everything that you need so
it's very important for your in physics
or chemistry computer science whatever
you'll have some notations that you work
with you want to be able to enter those
into Mathematica notebook and do
computations with them you want them to
be live and working that is the goal of
this sort of session and indeed of
typesetting in Mathematica and so this
is what will attempt to go through and a
reasonable hopefully interactive way
with you here okay so this talk in
particular will cover boxes and the
representation of typeset structures I'm
going to talk about make boxes and make
expressions and so that these two
functions enable the front-end to talk
to the colonel back and forth and so by
overriding these functions we can enter
and we can affect our own new notations
I'm going to talk in detail about
template boxes as etai is mentioned I'll
talk about the notation package and how
you can use that and an easy way to
create your own sort of notations and
then I'll talk about style sheets how to
catch them up as eat I talked on and
then miscellaneous topics
okay so let's restate our goal here our
goal is that we've got some for instance
if you've got some a partial in physics
that might be an aid if operator and so
we want to make that work or or even
something like a skate PD escape
[Music]
different angle escape PD escape control
underscore here and make that a plus of
like something like X cubed right now
Mathematica doesn't understand that but
we want Mathematica to be able to
actually maybe in the end take that to a
PDE plus of X cubed something else like
that so there's there's the normal form
that we've got of these boxes here and
Mathematica doesn't understand that what
we want is it to be able to Mathematica
to be able to have use this pd+
internally and then of course you know
Mathematica you can make your own
pattern matching rewrite rules and so on
to make pd+ do something that you want
so the goal was to be able to take some
input like this and be able to to make
it internally work like that okay so
let's talk about boxes a little bit so
eat I mentioned this and he's going over
it reasonably quickly if we take a look
at some some box here to actually look
at the box expression underneath there's
this show expression very important
should learn it know at command shift e
and so if we take a look at that
expression you can actually see the
underlying boxes here this X cubed right
here is actually a superscript box and I
can actually even edit the actual boxes
themselves command shift E again back
and forth command shift E and evaluate
it and we get X to the 4th plus 2 so I
can edit the boxes I can edit our
expressions in normal Mathematica you're
all very used to that I can edit the
underlying boxes to do the exact same
thing and of course when I type some
sort of complex integral like below you
probably all know that you know you can
type these characters if not there on
the complete characters palette and and
so right there that's just an integral
character once I get a sub script on
there we see that is indeed subscript
box and of course if I get the other
there and get an escape infinity escape
we can see that's a sub superscript box
and so on and so I can type the rest of
this integral to be able to you know do
things and make computations with it
okay
so let's let's take a look at this in
and what goes on underneath and to do
this I'm going to be using two dynamics
and so if you don't know too much about
the dynamic system it allows us to sort
of link the front-end and the kernel
here and this input field of a dynamic
of the boxes means as I type in this
input field right here I type stuff it
will set the value of the boxes to the
the input we've got in boxes
continuously and this output just shows
that what this value the boxes is so if
I type a plus B I actually see what is
the underlying boxes the front ends
actually using and so it's using this
row box of a plus B and and here we have
times C and we've noticed already that
the Box parser has grouped our
expressions we know that B times C is as
a tighter precedence x has a tighter
precedence than plus and so we see this
grouping already in our structures okay
and so now as we type the sum expression
here escape and escape I start seeing
there's a subscript box and here now I
see a sub superscript box and I see this
this complex infinity I see this double
struck e this exponential e I see
another superscript box the minus X and
I see a superscript box the row box and
the double start date escape and and so
we finally see as we've entered all of
this various bits this is the underlying
expression so this is basically what the
sort of front end is editability as I
type stuff into Mathematica I see
there's the the underlying box parser
this is exposing the beating heart of
the underlying box parser how it will
form and reform the various expressions
to have the boxes that represent what
we've typed okay so that's about boxes
and you might think well okay that's
just sort of some typeset we've got some
math e bits but not everything is boxes
but if we take a look at some random
expression here
with you know wines and we can you know
move it around and extend them and do
stuff with them as that boxes well
indeed if we take a look underneath it's
a graphics box of a wine box and so
graphics themselves are our boxes and
here we have a Bezier curve box and you
might think well you know that's
probably you know it's a smooth spline
but no indeed it's a Bayesian curve box
with line boxes and point boxes and so
on so all graphics are also boxes and
indeed our controls if we take a look at
them we've seen interface construction
and styling if we have a style it turns
out to be a style box a button here as
we can evaluate it it will evaluate as
we expect here this turns out to be
underneath a button box and and likewise
with if we've got these two dynamics
here's a nice you know sort of semi
simple example of a dynamics they're
linked we have as we move the slider the
value of M n changes and this dynamic
here just represents that change and we
see underneath our control is actually a
slider box and our dynamic here is a
dynamic box so everything in the front
end is boxes so it's very important that
we can actually override this to
actually allow an effect our own
overriding of the notations in
Mathematica and I can now actually say
that that's sort of my area that I work
on and and Wolfram research sort of in
charge of along with John and everybody
else that that does it the boxes and so
in the front end the main front end and
then now and our new and be light core
locators a box yep yep so everything's
boxes so so in an intact yep everything
space well there's other stuff besides
boxes it's it's too much but but it's
it's the the language which you'll use
to customize and everything you'll be
dealing with the boxes
there's there's of course the styles on
a style sheet there's there's others and
when you get a notebook expressions
you'll see cells and box data and you
know notebooks and other stuff but
primarily that underlying bits as you
interact is this boxes okay so the
question is when we evaluate stuff what
actually goes on so if I if I take a
look at some evaluation like this I get
the derivative of sine Y over two is you
know cosine Y over two we all know
that what's actually happened as we go
through here so what what happens is the
front end basically has this list of
boxes it has this sort of box expression
and that needs to be sort of parsed into
an actual kernel expression it's that
that those boxes are actually parsed
into something a lot more like D of sign
of Y over 2 comma Y and then of course
goes through evaluation to get something
like cosine Y over 2 and cosine Y over 2
of course then turns around and it's
displayed in the front end back into a
normal form in terms of boxes so like
that so basically what's happening is we
start off with this box structure with
this which is this sign this expression
partial Y sine Y over 2 that gets parsed
to a kernel expression which is just
this D of sine Y over 2 that gets
evaluated into this form and then of
course it gets displayed in terms of
boxes back in the front end so we start
off with the box structure we we start
off with the box structure it isn't uh
it might be on Windows sorry there's
some yeah so right we'll fix that after
so so this box structure it starts off
at a box structure it gets parsed into a
kernel expression that's and it happens
via make expression in other words we
take boxes we make an expression from
them to get a kernel expression
evaluation occurs to get a new kernel
expression and then we go make boxes
through formatting to get a new box
structure and so this is how we perceive
formatting to occur formatting and
parsing to occur but it actually goes
through the stage of going through the
kernel so the trick now is so we've got
parsing is make expression we've got
formatting as make boxes we need to be
able to override those and if we can
then we can turn around and create our
own notations so let us start and
actually do that so this is our notation
we were talking about escaped PD escape
here a plus and something like a the
Mathematica doesn't understand that
right now and we want it to actually
look like PD plus of thee which it does
understand so how do we do this well
we're going to do make expression and on
which boxes so we're gonna try and do
make expression on these boxes and so I
use commit I use command shift to e to
get the boxes out of here on this in
standard form and right now Mathematica
doesn't know what to do with those boxes
but it does know what to do with these
boxes here if I if I grab the boxes for
the output here and I do this make
expression on those boxes and standard
form it does know what to do so what
we're going to do is we're going to tell
Mathematica what this means in terms of
boxes it does know how to work with like
so and now this particular input will
actually work but of course it's just
for this input if I change that to a
queue it still doesn't know what's going
on because of course we haven't changed
it here so if I change that to a queue
here and change this to a queue here I
now have something that works for us
right for Q underscore for instance we
have something that works in general for
Q or 40 or for any you know T cubed and
so on so now we've created the parsing
we've created a rule actually to make
parsing work by by rewriting the boxes
that it doesn't understand in terms of
boxes that it does know how to make an
expression from okay so that's good but
what happens we want this to output as
well so we want this not to just be an
input we want this to be output so we
need now to have this form to to work in
the output and so we need it be able to
make expression on some some expression
like this
and we'll make this general for any tea
and of course but sorry I'm on a new
MacBook and the keys are a bit bit weird
I don't know if I like the touch bar
it's not so cool but anyway so the the
make expression of this what kind of
boxes is this going to be
well it's going to be those boxes here
we can copy them and copy those boxes
it'll be this expression here and of
course this T will be something like
that but of course T's an expression so
it needs to be further made into boxes
so we need to call make boxes again on
this again as follows and now we have
this working and parsing is a bit of a
muxes yeah
there we go okay and so this works and
it now has of course the rightful form
as you'd expect and and it works with
both input and output okay and so
there's the rules in the notebook that
say exactly this now that of course it's
a working and functioning notation we
can actually make a sort of for instance
a linearity rule here's the linearity
rule over this partial plus it works as
we'd expect and it has the rightful form
so just to summarize again the make
expression is we're taking boxes and
that boxes that doesn't know how to make
and two boxes it does know how to make
and from the boxes we're writing an
expression in terms of boxes in the
output so that that's the process of
creating the notation let me just
mention a few other things before I hand
it over to the people in the audience to
you can try this on your laptop and
we've got Lou and Aaron and etai to
actually help you if you've got any
questions and I'm going to give you some
exercises so if we have some input like
this plus y squared plus this pd+ of
some t here we can enter the notations
sometimes linearly and this is this
trick that I mentioned in the talk we
can actually get a traditional form a
standard form or an input form here just
by cycling around by our various keys
and so it's sometimes useful to just
enter it in linearly and then convert to
standard form and of course this only
works if if the thing makes syntactic
sense if I put a plus on the end for
instance that doesn't you know
Mathematica can't work with that
I can't convert it to different forms so
it's got to make some tactic sense and
one of the other things we sometimes do
is put like a print of two in there and
so as we you know as we go around all
the various different forms we see it's
not printing so we're not leaking
anything our typesetting if there was a
two appearing below then some evaluation
would be happening which would be dead
okay so right onto this notation this is
your first exercise in this workshop so
here this is built into Mathematica a
nice function notation I like it looks
you know traditional mathematical form
of a function and it works in standard
form
so that's good it works you know r+ t
something here does what we want but the
function so in other words the make
expression is working it understands
these boxes but the formatting isn't
working it's it's output as function
would like that to appear like the input
how do we do that so we need a make
boxes rule that's your exercise I'll
give you a minute to think about that
come on ye you've got to be able to get
it what others stand you probably know
exactly Oh at least at least if you
don't get it at least you can start
thinking about it and then you see the
answer and then we'll hopefully go in oh
yeah
so that's escape function escape yeah
it's nice isn't it
yeah yep so ya know it's it's been
around yep it's this escape function
escape
well you need to create your notation
for right here being a function so okay
son ye we're done almost okay I'll go on
with the with the answer here so so what
we want is of course we want to make
boxes we want to be able to make boxes
in other words we're given an expression
and our expression here is something
like function a of T we want to be able
to make that into in standard form and
we want this to be any sort of parameter
here a parameter here look premiere here
in standard form and what should those
boxes actually be well they should be if
we went and copied that
we get those boxes and paste it in here
and of course it's not going to be that
we need to make book bank boxes of tea
come a third form and we also need so in
other words we need to make both
arguments here this keyboard is the
travel key the treble stroke is actually
different john was asking me did it make
a difference and I didn't really think
so until today when I was practicing
this it really does make a difference
okay so we have some some function that
oh yeah it really this skate keys in the
wrong place at the travel no it's just
all wrong so that works as we want and
it has the right there has the right
output and it has the rightful form as
we've created here okay so that that's
that's one example let's move on now
that you've got that and you've got this
sort of simple example let's move it
down to up and down so maybe we're
dealing in physics a spin glass or
something else like that we have an up
arrow plus you know it'd be down arrow
arrow here something else like that and
we want Mathematica to be able to
understand that in terms of of a plus
down of B okay so create the notation to
to go from one to the other that's the
task ye
yep
yep
oh yeah yeah sure yeah well the whole
trick is of course you copy the boxes
that Mathematica puts in so like
whenever I'm creating my own notations I
never try and is it a subscript of you
just type it in see it and then you copy
yeah I you it does the break-up matching
with Comanche fee but yeah it is a bit
right okay so let's let's take a look at
this particular example here let's do
the the first of all let's make it pars
so right now that's not parsing so we
need make expression what are the boxes
that we're going to make pars so we get
here get the actual boxes sub super
superscript box here with that in
standard form and what's it going to be
well it's just going to be of course
make expression of the boxes for up of a
which it does know how to make and so we
grab that in standard form and of course
this is this is not this is not just a
this is of course any expression here
it's just a and of course now our our
expression works up if a works let's
make let's do the same one for down now
same sort of rule down arrow and of
course this is just down and now our
whole expression parses as we want but
of course when we enter it again it's
not formatting so we need now some make
boxes rules pretty simple make boxes
rules and what are we going to make
we're gonna make of course up up a
whatever in standard form standard form
is what are the boxes for that well we
know what they are they're these boxes
here
yeah
yeah that would that would be really
nice thank boxes of a comment standard
for him as we've got and so the similar
one for the down
yeah really it's nice and fast but yeah
yeah so okay
and so finally now our our formatting is
working as with wine it has you know
plus plus Q and it has you know the full
form the correct full form it's with one
okay so that's parsing and formatting of
the spin up and down spins the next one
would like to actually talk about is
formatting of a matrix so normally now a
list list of lists is considered a list
of lists in traditional form it looks
like a matrix input form it's a list of
lists standard form a list of Lists and
in traditional form it's a matrix so the
question is how do it and of course
Mathematica understands this so we don't
need any parsing rules we just need a
formatting rule how do we make
Mathematica make this nice how do we how
do we have a standard form that looks
like a matrix so create a make boxes
rule to make our a list of lists look
like that that's the next question how
would we do that
so at the beginning here we're not going
to worry about evaluation so now we need
something
[Music]
so what we needed to so to do this we
need to make to basically take and and
map make boxes over the the various
arguments that we've got and so if we we
try a normal map of course it's not it
quite the right level we need it to map
over each of the individual arguments so
we can turn around here and just map at
a different level like so and of course
this is now instead of dad it's gonna be
and make boxes of its argument comment
in standard form function that's what
we're gonna do over the various
arguments and of course what what is the
actual output that we want it to look
like well we want it to look like this
ooh big expression there but let's just
grab it anyways do the bracket matching
copy that and so we want it to be these
boxes here but we don't want the grid
box alignment option we don't want the
grid box spacings so that's all fine so
we want it to look like that the inner
bit is what we're gonna replace by this
bit here and replace this argument here
by our a and wallah that's what we want
and now as we see we cycle to our input
form a traditional form their standard
form and it's sort of working except you
notice it's now four we had two plus two
and as I go to a standard form
traditional form but as this traditional
form an input form but as we go to
standard form there it's evaluated we've
got a leak we've got an evaluation leak
which is bad we don't want to do this
each I said it's bad I think it's bad
it's bad so how do we get around this
well we've got to worry about evaluation
and so here if we take a look at what's
being evaluated you've got to be very
careful evaluation slips in and lots of
places it'll slip in here at the matrix
Q it'll slip in at the application of
this function this needs to be a pure
function with a hold all and it needs to
be under valuated on this argument and
so I can turn around and put here matrix
Q of unevaluated of a and make sure my
function here that I'm mapping over here
is actually go back to a function go
here they can't function it's Li be some
variable here they come here at the end
and make sure it's hold all and of
course we need a none evaluated around
here
like that and so that I think it's all
that gets rid of all the evaluation
stuff we're gonna turn around and quit
our colonel just to make sure that we
don't have previous rules there go here
and I'll go back up and try 2 plus 2
input traditional standard formal so
we've done it and we've done it and so
right now as we have any particular
matrix in standard form we enter it you
know control you know a Q something else
it'll appear as a matrix in our output
form okay so again through a make boxes
rule and so that gives you an idea about
the holding I'll talk briefly about tag
boxes tag boxes as we mentioned these
are in invisible boxes that go in the
typesetting structures that appear there
so for instance here in this output when
I when I enter that again that let me
just get rid of our notations everything
was added before quit that we enter that
we actually get in the output a matrix
we don't get a list of lists anymore and
so you wonder well how did this happen
how do we get this how do we get this
list of Lists not get a list of Lists
and it's because underneath there's this
tag box so this grid box here is wrapped
in this tag box so in that tag box when
make expression takes a look at that and
says oh there's this box there's a tag
box thing I'm not going to make it into
a list of Lists I'm gonna make it into a
grid so we can actually turn around and
even just delete that that grid right
there and it'll come back and be format
it as a list of lists so here there's
this invisible tag box underneath and
here the tag box is gone and we've got a
list of Lists other than that well have
since moved on from tags block tag boxes
is a major source of typesetting it's
now moved on to template boxes they are
used if we take a look at you know a
function template here tabbing through
them and so on
we've got tag boxes in there and they're
used in like Mouse appearance and and
you know as we move over the mouse
there's a there's a tag box in there and
manipulates in some of the other places
but we won't talk about that too much
okay
so now I'd like to talk about the
notation package
what's it useful for well creating these
notations these
make boxes and make expressions it's
kind of hard sometimes to get things in
the right places so let's take a look at
this one example I've got here this ring
plus and ring times doesn't actually
work so how do we create a notation for
that we could go to the notation pallet
here and paste a notation and this is
the external external external boxes
they underscore + and we do escape get
our ring ring + operator there and
that's the external thing we're trying
to recognize and that's going to be
recognized as a ring + of a underscore
comma the underscore like so and so that
if we do the same thing now for a
multiplication we see a ring times here
and now this thing will parse and format
it has the right parsing and the right
formatting and so what happens is this
these notation statements are basically
you can think of it as a transpiler
we're taking these rules these box rules
and we're creating the notation package
creates equivalent make boxes and make
expression rules to actually to affect
the notation that you're trying to work
with so the 1 goes both ways is it's
just one is just in fact let me just
quit that and actually turn around
though the kernel
I'm going to quit this there is ways to
remove the particular notations but I
won't go into that and so here we have
it formatting and it doesn't understand
it at all if we take a look at this is
just double long right arrow and we go
here and you have this is a double one
right arrow just the one way so you know
we enter the notations for that we will
see the ring plus will format as a ring
plus that ring x will not format if that
and so in other words by this arrow it
directs it what are the different
directions that we're doing so right now
from here we can see it'll actually
parse into this expression but here
it'll parse animal format yep
exactly this is a compiler this is
basically the notation statement
basically turns around and it compiles
that into rules for make expression to
make boxes and in fact let me show you
here let me get exactly this go to here
and type x action print notation rules
and we can actually see one of them and
so these rules this is the rules
the notation package is actually
generating and it's quite similar it
says notation make expression instead of
make expression and there's some of the
notation backtick private gunk but other
than that it's sort of like a make
expression equals make expression of
something else and we've got this ring
plus operator here so it's it's
rewriting this and something which it
doesn't understand into something it
does and likewise make boxes and so this
notation statement is generating these
rules which Mathematica then uses to
affect the notations and so you can
study these output rules which is kind
of useful to actually see what's going
on indeed yeah that's a it's a good
point here so normally you don't
actually see underscores on both sides
you just see it on sort of the one side
but I when I designed it when I put this
in I seem right to me and since it's
going back and forth I put it in on both
sides yep okay and so one of the other
things you'll actually see in here as
well you'll see instead of make boxes
here's the notation make boxes instead
of here being make boxes it's actually
parenthesize and so that gets the right
prints parenthesis is actually a
generalization of make boxes but I won't
go too much into the details but make
sure everything has the right brackets
around it and it looks good
okay so one of the other things I wanted
to mention here in terms of complexities
to do with this is that if we have a
normal a times B plus C plus D and I
look at that in terms of full forms
we'll actually see it sparse flat we
have a plus times a B and then we've got
a see comedy here so here with our rules
that we were actually doing
with our notation rules here we're we're
not actually parsing flat if I put if I
get this here put that end put a D here
and actually take a look at the full
form of all of that we'll see we we
parse the ring the ring times instead of
the times in the same way but there's a
ring plus and then there's an outer ring
plus sometimes we want that to be
actually flat we want a flat operator so
to actually do that instead of our
notations here that we've actually got
we can turn around and put in an infix
notation so we do this via the following
and of course would turn around and make
our ring plus the an infix notation for
ring plus and similarly we do ring times
and now our structure instead of did I I
didn't evaluate the kernel yep
got to do that
yeah
right
and now who we have the same form our
times our ring times is pars flat and
our ring plus has pars flat exactly like
the the normal that's internally to
Mathematica okay so as an exercise in
actually using this it might be you can
turn around and create again your up and
down notations using the the notation
package it's it's not that hard I'll
give you a second to try that right
there
yiii okay so so we we want some of the a
with the up arrow here was the be a
underscore put an underscore on the
other side as we've got here and
similarly down arrow is down and now
we've got the the notations we want up
of a + down of our and standard form and
they work they pars and they work as
you'd expect okay so to quickly enter
notations as well eat I mentioned the
fact that you've got these various input
aliases that you can actually use edit
adding them in Mathematica with the
notation package is actually quite easy
you just give it a short form you give
it the various boxes and now we can do
to escape and input alias escape I'm
sorry to add our own and of course if we
want to actually use this one here this
opu we can just type escape opu escape
and we've got the boxes and does what we
want and heads the rightful form etc so
adding our own full forms like the
limits or the other things that you saw
you ty use it's quite easy
insert yep
bug bug it's it's it's been one of those
things that's on my radar for ages but
it probably forced Aaron now okay right
right cool
okay so one of the other things we need
to mention before we mentioned template
boxes is base styles so so normally in
fact in a normal text editor is if I if
I start typing in a normal cell and that
that cell is italic and I just you know
click click off there and click next to
it and start typing again I get italic
and so it sort of captures the style
that's that's traditional of what
happens and so if I have a style box the
same thing happens here so this is Royal
boxes and roll boxes I don't know if
I've used roll boxes before if I enter
it here as style if I enter a box
expression it's just a normal expression
in the kernel that kernel can deal with
it in fact we make use of being able to
deal with it in the hole this is an 11-2
I hit some weird key combination I think
it was a yeah this Mac is decidedly
annoying
based on here we go so yeah so the raw
boxes just takes that and and puts the
the boxes as an output expression here
and so you see it's just outputted this
as the boxes but if we type right next
to that we see it's actually captured
the style which is not exactly what we
want
we want to be able to create typesetting
units that are self-contained that are
that are completely encapsulated and
here if we do this we can actually see
with this by using this base style we
can include whatever styles font sizes
magnifications what whatever we want in
in the particular style and then right
next to it there they're constrained to
just that particular box so so that's
something very useful which we were
about to make useful use of and the base
style on the default base style John and
I added that I'm not too sure a while
ago and it's in most boxes that are
around almost all your boxes will have
that as an option okay so now we get to
this template boxes that each I was
talking about and how we can use those
and and influence our typesetting with
them so let's actually talk about them
right now so here we have a binomial of
n comma K and traditional form so you've
seen this grid box before you probably
think this is a grid box with some
brackets and when I take a look at the
underlying boxes we're gonna see
something like that but actually we
don't we see this form box to the
template box with these two arguments n
comma K and this binomial thing is like
what how is that looking like the
binomial that we actually see in fact if
I go in and I change them here to change
that to an M evaluate it it evaluates to
the right thing so somehow just through
the name of this this binomial here and
and the various arguments it gets the
right formatting and it gets the right
evaluation so knowing that why don't we
actually even just change this let's
just be a little bit tricky change that
to a Bessel J and it looks like a vessel
J function we evaluate it it even
evaluates like a vessel J if we go in
here and you know change that to a
vessel K again it evaluates like it
that's okay where you could go in here
change it to look if I can type
correctly
and trippy
ha ha yep we hit North Chandra
Alessandra P function and and and it
works as one would expect and of course
it has the right tool tip and we can as
a template we can't actually select the
P we can then select the K or the M and
it works as we as we put this in it
deletes the various arguments we tab
back and forth between them and it works
as would sort of expect ok so so how is
this actually working underneath let's
actually talk now about the this
template boxes so here I've got a
template box I'm going to display it
I've got this it's got two arguments a
and B and it's got this weirdo tag
foolish and repeat just sort of made it
up but it's got this display function
that each I talked about so what I can
do is I can actually take that display
function here and I can take a look and
we can apply it to the arguments of the
template box here and it gives another
box expression so that and in terms of
our full form here with the display
function applied to the arguments of the
template box gives another complete box
and if we take a look at that in terms
of raw boxes it has an output and indeed
that's exactly how the template box will
display so what what happens is the
template box as it needs to know how do
i display this function it goes and it
gets the arguments it plugs them into
this display function here to get
another box expression and that's how
the output of our template box actually
looks so it's integral part is the
display function to determine how our
template boxes actually look and it's
got this foolish and repeat egg here and
that right now indicates how the thing
is actually evaluates if we evaluate
that all of a sudden it gives this
foolish and repeat I could have you know
change this to Quidditch for instance or
some they had spelling of it and and of
course it it will evaluate as quidditch
of a comment B so this here it's already
got a built-in make expression rule for
for how this should actually work from
these boxes it just applies this this
function on the head of the two
arguments so that's great
so now all we need to do is actually
change our display functions and get it
to work with the right display functions
to make the changes that we actually
want so let's go back here get a
binomial ad Q to it get some other
binomial get that in traditional form
and and take a look at now changing our
binomials so we can go here to the style
sheet and actually figure out where is
our binomial on your style sheet you'll
find here we'll go to the core we find
line and we see it down here it's really
small so I'm just going to copy that go
back here paste it in here
close that section again and go to 200%
and now we can actually you can actually
see with the binomial what is the
display function and now we can see
where that the the brackets come from
and our grid box comes and so our grid
box and our brackets come from this
current display function for the
binomial so we can change this to
whatever display function we actually
want let's take a look at C and you know
choose things and you know okay
something else like that and of course
we just grabbed this function we grabbed
the boxes for that the subscript or
script box and we're gonna plug it in to
our display function here and so we do
that plug it in change this to be it's
got to be a function that returns boxes
so that's the first argument here this
is the second argument and now when I
hit command shift D we're going to see
all of our binomials change to our cnk
notation and the deed they did so this
of course this is still just a template
box so if I copy this and I get a new
notebook and blow it up
at 200% I'm copying the template box so
in this style sheet I don't have the new
notation so of course it's just a
binomial so if I can take that now go
back here you know edit this to be an R
come back copy that paste it back into
this node notebook and I get back
the notation in this notebook so so
really the template box on the style
sheet is guiding via the display
function how all of these things should
actually look and behave okay and so
that's the power of template boxes
so let's actually state a bit more
formally what a template box is
a template box basically it's a box it
has these box arguments and it has this
tank and normally the tag is a string
and way back when we made it so that if
the tag is a string it'll look on the
style sheet see if it has a style of
that name and we'll use those options
so we're it's using the display function
and that display function will plug in
the box arguments get a generated box
and use it and display it in that way
okay
and so the the template boxes here can
be nested they work as would expect they
have the nice tooltips and now it only
remains to make a make expression for
these particular rules so so here's an
example your last your last exercise in
the remaining nine minutes before
questions or including questions I think
we have a my communicator in physics if
we have a you know a commutator is
something a dot B minus B dot a is a
typical thing in physics with operators
and so here's a my commutator it has a
display function built-in and luckily
right on the the style sheet we actually
have this display function for a my
commutator so you can you could possibly
change it or or or not but because it's
on the style sheet we can actually get
that display function right there and we
can actually get rid of it and we will
get the exact same form it has the right
input form and it outputs as my
commutator so it parses it works it's
got a nice tooltip your job is to write
a make boxes role so that this input of
my commutator will have a nice output
back to my community
yeah
fully so so basically this is exact same
trick from before so we can we can add a
make boxes rule and we want to make
boxes for a my commutator object here on
a and B and standard form to be equal to
what are the boxes we want well we want
it to be these boxes here so we want it
to be this template box and so we put
that in we put in this of course has to
be make boxes of a comma standard form
and the same way with being here and
there is our rule now we we can parse
format all of the various things appear
as it should we we can go back here get
the input form you know change it T Q
and so on and it actually works and so
now we can make some sort of linearity
rules if we want for instance and
commutator is it's common that they're
linear in their first arguments here so
we make that as you know a plus a and R
square plus you know W underscore and
you know Q is equal to this thing we've
got here a Q plus W and so we see it
that's that's our linearity rule that
we're adding
and so we've evaluated that and now we
can come in here and you know Q plus R
plus T you know with respect to Y or
something we get some linearity okay the
one final thing to mention is that
interpretation function allows us it's
automatic and so it wraps the style name
around the particular arguments and so
we can actually copy these complex
template box structures and put them on
you know emails or something else and it
nicely will format them according to
again our rules so they're great they
work nicely for for inter communication
and they're fantastic and in fact most
of the normal typesetting that Lou and
eat I and everybody else does now all
our modern you know special functions
and other things are all done through
through template boxes okay I run out of
time a little bit so I won't mention the
the syntax form options I will mention
that graphics of course as contact
sensitive and it's typesetting the
graphics of course here we've got a
point
just type sets as just the expression
but inside of graphics it's a point box
okay and one other interesting note is
that in fact our our whole typesetting
model is being developed independently
of course of CSS but interestingly all
of our the box model is very similar
that our image margins or frame margins
as similar to margins and padding and a
lot of the concepts from style sheets
are are somewhat somewhat the same I
don't think the CSS HTML guys copied us
we certainly didn't copy them but it's
interesting to see there's some natural
underlying sort of structure that we've
converged on the same or close to the
same sorts of models on underlying
underlying the way things work ok so to
create a template box notation you first
enter a structure in 2d you copy the
boxes into display function put it on
the style sheet create a make boxes rule
and maybe for bonus points create a
input alias for the notation I know this
has come probably quite thick and fast
if you haven't seen this before it's a
wealth of information but at the same
time it gives you an idea an outline of
the steps that are needed and hopefully
you can go away and and and play with it
a little bit to actually get your
notations it's not as you see I'm doing
it live it's not that hard to actually
do your own notations and so you can
create them and then and then use them
in your field of study ok
[Applause]